[Risas]
[Música]
México lindo y querido México vive sus
últimos meses bajo el mando de Andrés
Manuel López Obrador con mucha
diferencia uno de los perfiles políticos
más rupturistas que ha pasado por la
jefatura del Estado Azteca es hora por
tanto de empezar a evaluar y lo primero
de todo es recordar que el líder de
morena el movimiento regeneración
nacional prometía impulsar una enorme
transformación del país esto incluía por
supuesto una estrategia de seguridad
nacional completamente nueva Al fin y al
cabo la seguridad O mejor dicho la falta
de seguridad es uno de los grandes
problemas de México sino el más
importante de todos López Obrador choca
con el ejército mexicano en su camino a
las presidenciales de 2018 el político
ha subrayado desde hace un mes las
violaciones de Derechos Humanos
cometidas por los militares en el
combate al narcotráfico polémica por la
propuesta de amnistía criminales en
México del precandidato presidencial
López Obrador durante la última década
López Obrador ha criticado la estrategia
de combate al crimen organizado a través
del del ejército y la Marina en las
calles sustituyendo a las fuerzas
civiles policiales sin embargo al final
parece que México cambió a amlo más de
lo que amlo cambió a México al menos en
materia de seguridad amlo anuncia 50.000
millones de pesos adicionales para la
guardia nacional amlo buscará que el
ejército y la Marina realicen labores
permanentes de Seguridad Pública para
abatir la inseguridad La pregunta es es
en este campo muy diferente el México
que deja López Obrador del que recibió
en 2018
pues lo cierto es que sí pero de forma
muy diferente a lo que podríamos
imaginarnos Y a lo que prometió el
propio amlo porque lo cierto Es que en
los últimos años el gobierno mexicano ha
ampliado exponencialmente el rol de las
fuerzas armadas los militares tienen
ahora a su cargo un montón de cometidos
desde gestionar la seguridad interior
hasta administrar aeropuertos obras e
incluso empresas del estado y eso
queridos amigos ha hecho que aquí en
visualpolitik nos hagamos unas cuantas
preguntas Cómo demonios explica que los
militares hayan ganado tanto peso con un
presidente que supuestamente quería
desmilitarizar el país que provocó
semejante metamorfosis política Hasta
qué punto dejarlo un país militarizado
Pues bien vayamos manos a la obra con
ello pero antes Te has parado a pensar
en lo que te estás perdiendo por no usar
surfshark lo primero de todo y más
importante es la seguridad en la red con
surfshark tu actividad online está
fuertemente protegida cifrada y a salvo
de ojos curiosos además con Clean web te
despides de los anuncios y el malware Y
qué pasa con los emails con surfshark
caller te enterarás al instante si
alguien ha intentado filtrar tu
información pero aún hay más surfshark
es la primera VPN comercial con
servidores en más de un centenar de
países vamos algo así como un pasaporte
global a golpe de clic podrás acceder a
cualquier contenido bloqueado por
ubicación Y si te preocupa tener que
elegir en Qué dispositivo usarlo
tranquilo con la misma cuenta puedes
proteger todos tus dispositivos ya sea
tu móvil tu tablet la tele o el
ordenador además por ser parte de la
comunidad visualpolitik podrás disfrutar
de tres meses extra totalmente gratis
usando el código polytic acabado en K y
dicho esto continuemos con nuestro vídeo
de hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
fuera de México Quizás no sea tan
conocido pero las fuerzas armadas de
este país tienen una historia única en
América Latina haberse enfrentado con
todas las grandes potencias occidentales
estábamos por supuesto hablando de la
guerra que liberaron México y Estados
Unidos entre los años 1846 y 1848 y
también a la intervención militar de
Francia en México entre 1862 y 1867 un
conflicto en el que tanto el Reino Unido
como España se sumaron a las fuerzas
francesas con todo a principios del
siglo XX los principales problemas eran
ya internos El ocaso del dictador
Porfirio Díaz sumergió a las fuerzas
armadas en un caos de idas y venidas que
duró hasta la Revolución Mexicana allá
por la década de los años 20 a partir de
Entonces los uniformados mexicanos
sirvieron como fieles Guardianes de la
Constitución lo que durante décadas fue
prácticamente equivalente a estar a las
órdenes del Pri el partido que gobernó
México de forma ininterrumpida durante
más de 70 años en cualquier caso lo
importante es que esta tradición
constitucional caló hondo entre los
uniformados además durante el siglo XX
México evitó cualquier Aventura
militarista por lo que a diferencia de
lo que ocurrió en América Latina las
fuerzas armadas mexicanas no
intervinieron en asuntos de estado es
decir aquí no hubo golpes ni generales
emocionados con la idea de imponer la
bota militar como sistema político
Quizás eso explica Por qué las fuerzas
armadas se han convertido en la
institución que mayor confianza
despierta y entre los mexicanos
sea como sea ahora el gobierno de amlo
le ha dado un giro de 180 grados al rol
de las fuerzas armadas en los asuntos de
estado amlo les ha metido de lleno en
espacios que hasta ahora han sido
tradicionalmente civiles hablamos de
Campos tampoco castrenses como estos dan
luz verde a una nueva empresa militar
para administrar complejo turístico en
las Islas Marías hablo entregará al
ejército el control de las aduanas en la
frontera el gobierno de López Obrador
compra Mexicana de Aviación la manejará
el ejército y tendrá pasajes low cost
ahora los mexicanos están viendo cómo de
repente los oficiales de las fuerzas
armadas empiezan a encargarse de la
gestión de empresas turísticas agencias
de telecomunicaciones o incluso del
control de la infraestructura energética
Esto es lo que se ha venido a conocer
como la militarización de México el peso
de las fuerzas armadas en el gobierno y
en el día a día es cada vez mayor y la
pregunta es hasta qué punto los
uniformados están cómodos con este nuevo
rol hasta dónde llega su nueva
influencia puede el ca muflaje verde
oliva provocar un cambio de paradigma en
el sistema político Azteca por qué hablo
está apostando todo a una institución
que hasta hace poco rechazaba queridos
amigos amigas como siempre en este vídeo
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas vamos por ello
la guerra contra el narco
no es ningún secreto México tiene un
problema por encima de todos los demás
el narcotráfico un problema tan grande
que frecuentemente llega a sobrepasar
las capacidades convencionales de las
fuerzas de seguridad eso al menos es lo
que pensó el presidente Felipe Calderón
cuando en 2006 le declaró la guerra a
los narcos como es subrayado hoy el
crimen organizado representa la mayor
amenaza para la seguridad la libertad y
la tranquilidad de los mexicanos
es un enemigo que no conoce límites de
esta forma a partir de finales del
2006 del ejército Para apoyar a la
policía en operativos contra los
cárteles poco a poco la asistencia
militar se fue haciendo cada vez más
común hasta que prácticamente se
convirtió en el operativo habitual
Entonces los territorios que lograban
ser asegurados permanecían bajo control
militar
Asimismo en paralelo se comenzaron a
crear grupos de autodefensa también
conocidos Como las guardias comunitarias
estos grupos estaban compuestos por
familias agrarias que se armaban para
poder defenderse de los narcos Y sabéis
qué ocurrió entonces que los cárteles
también empezaron a armarse hasta los
dientes y ese fue el comienzo de una
terrible Pesadilla hallados en México 24
jóvenes rematados a tiros haya muertos a
dos investigadores de la matanza de 72
inmigrantes México arresta a cinco Zetas
por la masacre de 52 personas en el
casino de Monterrey los narcos Asesinan
en México a 11 músicos de una banda de
cumbia detuvieron en México el narco que
habría ordenado incinerar a los 43
estudiantes y Estos son tan solo unos
pocos ejemplos de decenas y decenas de
casos diferentes terrible al final la
guerra contra el narco terminó con un
colosal fracaso cuando caía un cartel
rápidamente surgía otro mientras la
violencia se multiplicaba con todo ni
Calderón ni tampoco su sucesor Enrique
Peña Nieto se atrevieron a modificar a
gran escala el rol de las fuerzas
armadas en la seguridad interior nadie
Quería dar muestras de debilidad nadie
excepto un candidato Andrés Manuel López
Obrador que en 2012 decía cosas como
estas porque tenemos que
ir sacando al ejército
de las calles el ejército no está
preparado para esta función es otro su
encargo es defender la soberanía
nacional y no debe de seguirse
exponiendo al ejército y ahí no quedó
todo más tarde en la campaña de 2018
amlo
intensificó sus críticas por aquella
época además surgieron varios casos de
abuso de autoridad incluso ejecuciones
extrasumarias en el marco de la guerra
contra el narco
por si fuera poco Genaro García Luna que
fue secretario de seguridad pública
durante el sexenio de Felipe Calderón y
Salvador Cienfuegos ex titular de la
secretaría de la defensa nacional
durante el gobierno de Enrique Peña
Nieto estaban hasta el cuello de
denuncias de corrupción sobornos
trapicheos con los carteles y lavado de
dinero la guerra contra el narco había
entrado en una vía muerta y habló supo
sacar rédito electoral de ello
morena el movimiento regeneración
nacional arrasó En aquellos comicios de
2018 y se llevó algo más del 53% de los
votos y no solo logró la presidencia
también la mayoría parlamentaria para el
bloqueo oficialista en otras palabras el
gobierno estaba completamente en sus
manos para poder cumplir su programa
político sin embargo con las fuerzas
armadas optó por otro camino
completamente diferente
[Música]
de regañados a consentidos
amlo prometió sacar al ejército de las
calles Pero en cuanto llegó al poder
hizo Exactamente lo contrario López
Obrador se convirtió en presidente de
México el día 1 de diciembre de 2018
Pues bien tan solo durante sus dos
primeros años al frente del gobierno
mexicano militarizó Prácticamente la
misma cantidad de funciones que el resto
de gobiernos durante toda la década
anterior fijaos la mayor parte de tareas
y competencias traspasadas a los
militares tienen que ver con la gestión
de las obras públicas o el medio
ambiente sin ir más lejos hace poco aquí
en visualpolitik os hablamos del tren
Maya lo hicimos en un vídeo que montamos
en colaboración con Harvard
International review os acordáis pues
como os dijimos el tren Maya también
tiene al frente a los militares son
ellos quienes están pilotando su
construcción con todo incluso a pesar de
esta apuesta el gobierno de amlo sí
mantuvo alguna de sus promesas de
campaña respecto a las fuerzas armadas y
la seguridad al menos lo hizo durante
algún tiempo no
se Han detenido
a capos porque no es esa
nuestra función principal que no se
puede enfrentar el mal con el mal y
estamos convencidos que fue un error
grave un crimen
del haber declarado la guerra a la
delincuencia
al inicio del gobierno de Calderón pese
a todo desde la llegada de amlo al poder
el presupuesto de las fuerzas armadas
también se ha disparado Aunque claro
esto tiene trampa porque también han
asumido muchos más roles
[Música]
es decir que su peso en el presupuesto
público ha crecido y mucho aun cuando la
mejora en las funciones estrictamente
propias de las fuerzas armadas ha sido
mucho más limitada pero más presupuesto
nuevas funciones los militares empiezan
a ser omnipresentes en la administración
mexicana están por todas partes y la
pregunta es por qué amlo cambió tanto de
opinión Pues al parecer este fue
básicamente el motivo fijaos amlo expuso
entonces su doble plan para combatir
ambos problemas en primer lugar dijo
quiere dar a los militares más poder y
autoridad en las operaciones
antinarcóticos porque es el menos
corrupto de todos los organismos de
México y puede ser el más eficaz señores
sin embargo que para ello sería
necesaria una reforma constitucional
pero se mostró convencido de que podría
conseguirlo Es decir que amlo confiaba
en que los militares fueran menos
corruptos y por tanto más eficaces de
esta forma cuanto menos cosas queden en
manos de los civiles pues mejor que
mejor y eso es lo que explica que a
finales de 2022 anunciara una de sus
medidas más fijaos el congreso mexicano
aprueba que la guardia nacional pase a
control militar en medio de críticas y
que tiene esto de particular os
preguntaréis Pues que la guardia
nacional fue creada por el propio amlo
en 2019 con la idea de que fuese un
cuerpo civil y no militar era la forma
de sacar al ejército de la seguridad en
las calles sin embargo en 2022 tuvo que
regular Y de qué manera
acabo entregándole su juguete favorito
la recién creada Guardia nacional a los
militares la evolución de la
criminalidad y la violencia fue tan mala
que no le quedó otra no la gente en
nuestro país
le tiene confianza al ejército y le
tiene confianza
a la Secretaría de Marina y le tiene
confianza a la guardia Nacional de hecho
este no fue su único cambio de opinión
ni muchísimo menos hablo siempre
considera un error la guerra contra el
narcotráfico ahora sin embargo tiene una
opinión bastante diferente si cambia de
opinión ya viendo el problema que me
heredaron
Cómo enfrentar
el problema de la inseguridad Está bien
cambiar de opinión Cuando uno se
equivoca no pasa nada no lo estamos
reprobando ni mucho menos el problema es
que tampoco está claro que esta
estrategia esté funcionando o bueno Qué
diantres es que no está funcionando solo
tenemos que echar un vistazo a la
Gráfica de homicidios para darnos cuenta
de que esto no carbura bien fijaos
Casi casi dos décadas de intervención
militar en seguridad pública no han
logrado poner fin a la violencia
implacable de los carteles mexicanos y
han propiciado innumerables atrocidades
cometidas por soldados y marinos con
casi total impunidad hoy México no solo
es atravesando una de sus etapas más
violentas sino que además nunca antes
las fuerzas armadas habían tenido tanto
protagonismo ahora bien en esta ocasión
nuestra intención no es centrarnos en la
seguridad lo que nos importa en esta
ocasión es ver cómo hablo ha entrado en
una sorprendente carrera para
militarizar el país a toda velocidad y
eso queridos amigos es algo que trae
consigo algunos problemas queréis saber
de qué estamos hablando pues vamos con
ello
[Música]
las tres sombras de la militarización
mexicana
por regla general la militarización de
funciones y competencias públicas que
vayan Más allá del mundo castrense no
suele dar buen resultado básicamente
porque los militares tienen una
especialización muy particular Aunque es
verdad el caso de México es muy
particular la corrupción la violencia la
Falta de confianza en las instituciones
civiles en cualquier caso el proceso de
militarización que está sacando adelante
amlo plantea algunas dudas y algunos
problemas por ejemplo en primer lugar el
gobierno mexicano le está dando las
fuerzas armadas voluminosas partidas
presupuestarias para construir Obras
Públicas gestionar aeropuertos o
encargarse de campañas de publicidad
para centros turísticos El problema es
que esto reduce la capacidad de control
y fiscalización de todos esos fondos Por
qué pues exactamente por esto las
fuerzas armadas recurren
sistemáticamente a clasificar y
resguardar la información de sus
dependencias bajo el argumento de que no
se comprometa la seguridad nacional la
seguridad pública o la defensa nacional
rastrear y evaluar el uso de los
recursos públicos se vuelve entonces
sumamente complicado es lo que vimos que
está pasando con el tren Maya cada vez
son más los contratos que los militares
asignan de manera bastante discrecional
con pocahore una transparencia y sin
cumplir todos los requisitos legales de
las licitaciones públicas ya sabéis el
argumento es siempre el mismo seguridad
nacional
[Música]
en segundo lugar El razonamiento de
establecer administraciones militares
para revertir la corrupción en los
espacios civiles puede terminar
generando algo así como una lógica de
profecía autocumplida si hay menos
civiles y más militares a corto plazo es
posible que la corrupción caiga Pero
claro con menos transparencia más
atribuciones y profesionales menos
cualificados primera pregunta por qué no
va a terminar apareciendo también aquí
la corrupción y segunda acaso la
solución va a ser militarizar por
completo el estado esto cuanto menos
genera dudas y En tercer lugar tenemos
el que quizás es el mayor problema de
todos la temida pérdida de la
neutralidad el intento de que la
delegación a las fuerzas armadas amarre
las manos a futuros gobiernos también
implica una mayor participación de las
fuerzas armadas su progresiva
identificación con un proyecto político
específico y algo más serio implica la
pérdida de la neutralidad una
característica esencial para las
instituciones que cumplen tareas de
estado y que fuerzas armadas en México
por décadas lograron mantener amlo está
convirtiendo a los militares O al menos
a sus altos mandos en Auténticos
políticos y eso puede llegar a ser un
problema muy importante aceptaría los
militares a un gobierno que cuestione su
trabajo no tendrán acaso preferencia por
aquellos líderes políticos que les
prometan más influencia poder y
presupuesto y si son más honestos como
dice amlo para administrar puertos y
Obras Públicas Por qué no lo serían
directamente para gobernar ojo que la
historia nos enseña que tenemos que
preocuparnos de estas cosas
[Música]
en cualquier caso desde abril de este
2023 la Corte Suprema ha comenzado a
cuestionar todo este crecimiento sin
freno de los roles de las fuerzas
armadas en el gobierno de momento la
pugna de la corte con amlo no tiene un
desenlace claro sea como sea lo que sí
está demostrado Es que la militarización
de México ya no es un proyecto sino una
realidad pero ahora la pregunta es para
ti qué te parece que los militares
asuman cada vez más funciones que parece
una buena respuesta a la corrupción
estás A favor o en contra de qué otra
forma se pueden solventar los graves
problemas de corrupción Crimen y
narcotráfico que atraviesa México al fin
y al cabo Sin ellos es muy probable que
México se convirtiera en un país muy
próspero déjanos tu respuesta abajo en
los comentarios y recordad que con el
código politic acabado en K poder
disfrutar de tres meses extra totalmente
gratis con surfshark el link como
siempre abajo en la descripción si este
vídeo te ha resultado interesante
háznoslo saber dándole al botón de like
y no olvides suscribirte a visual
politik si es que aún no lo has hecho un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]